Drake you are the father xxxx extant
Toshio attends his own funeral at the
new video and I'm hanging out with Ross
Matthews and Marissa Jaret Winokur
spilling the tea on Big Brother and
RuPaul's Drag Race everybody this is the
daily Denny I'm Danny direct oh and it
is the end of the week which means it's
time for new music Friday Drake dropped
his 25 song double album scorpion and oh
does he have some things to get off his
chest and here's the T the rapper seems
to be confirming he's a dad on several
tracks the 31 year old addresses the
rumor that he fathered a now 8 month old
son named Adonis with a French former
adult film actress Sophie boo so that
wasn't had in my kid from the world I
was having the worst of my kid from she
not my lover like Billie Jean but the
kid is mine now we all know Drake has a
taste for sultry celebs I'm still not
over the love saga that was or is Drake
and reread I digress and now some fans
have died even deeper into the album
with many thinking Drake references his
past rumored romance with Bella Hadid in
finesse as for his baby mama Sophie a
source hold ET Drake is the opposite of
a deadbeat dad and has been financially
supporting her now there's so many songs
to get through literally this
confessional album is like 85 minutes
long and there's an amazing Michael
Jackson feature on the song don't matter
to me but you guys take a listen to
scorpion for yourself and let us know
your favorite tracks
I've moving on to another song everybody
is talking about slain rapper xxx Pinto
shown single sad catapulted to the top
of the Billboard Hot 100 soon after his
death and now there's an eerie
posthumous video for the song where xxx
attends his own funeral
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm something else huh
alright now I know this is a bit of a
hard pivot but I do want to end new
music Friday on a pause E beat and a
summer bop Charli XCX is coming for the
title of pop princess or even better
queen of summer with this experimental
banger focus
[Music]
[Music]
tell me you're not gonna be bump into
that all weekend by the way there's so
much new music Lawrence in the machine
has a new album out Teyana Taylor
OneRepublic dropped a new single so let
me know what you guys are listening to
right now alright but we've got to
switch gears now from music to reality
TV because last night was part two of
the two night premier of Big Brother
superfans and former Celebrity Big
Brother contestants Ross Matthews and
Marissa Jaret Winokur are hosting the
official after-show off the block right
here in our studio actually and I found
out just how intense their big brother
fandom is all right Big Brother season
56 now and you guys are back hosting the
official after-show and recap off the
block so you guys obviously hardcore
fans but you also know the game you guys
were both in Celebrity Big Brother you
won we won I want America's favorite she
won the whole game but we really got
there together so you guys are super
fans which is why you're perfect for
this after-show obviously but do you
guys like watch the live feeds like I
have to go to bed cuz we're shooting our
show today
and I I said an alarm for myself for
like one o'clock my mic says like I have
to stop watching his life is that so my
brain has been going mile minute I'm
like oh my god Steve's already awake
drinking coffee and I'm missing it yeah
I was shooting all day yesterday
draggers I still came home turned
everything on watch it's hardcore one I
would be doing it anyway we both would
cuz we love it so much and to now we
have this show off the block so people
are relying on us to to get the best
moment for case they missed some of it
to tell them what they don't know what's
going on and really break down what's
happening inside that Big Brother house
the live feeds are that bad yes you're
really seeing the full argument the full
conversation so yeah I'm actually using
this show off the block as an excuse
absolutely because I would be doing it
anyways but
now I have to do this for work so I need
to stay up all night make sense all
right initial impressions on the cast
you guys think well I feel honestly free
Sam I feel like Sam have gotten free Sam
okay we I was crying laughing because
it's a robot talking and crying it's so
weird and we're so connected yeah 100%
no future it's why big brother is the
weirdest show on TV yeah you're not
gonna get a talking robot crying and any
other program on any other channel I was
like what am i watching you know but
leave it to the producers of Big Brother
to really sort of find a new way to keep
this game fresh before I let you guys go
we need to talk about drag race cuz the
finale
okay I'm Marika Eureka no justice for
Eureka I got worse I'm hoarse because I
was screaming at my TV for a couple
reasons let's talk about the butterflies
real quick l'tesia
you were in the audience which by the
way you're a rock in a butterfly suit
yes and I did not know before I went
that Asia was doing a butterfly moment
my friend mr. Turk designed that suit
for me and I went and mr. Turkey and
when I saw that she was doing
butterflies I thought oh my god how
great because I'm wearing butterflies
and then when all the butterflies were
dying and falling any of them quick
would have worn the crown well and you
have to hand it to aquaria I'm not gonna
say who I was rooting for but I'll tell
aquaria will proudly represent RuPaul's
Drag Race for the next year oh good
season girl I am still gagging over that
lip-sync moment be sure to check out our
interviews with the Queen's of RuPaul's
Drag Race Season ten serving their best
Vangie you know the one miss Vangie miss
Vangie miss Benjie how to do it I gotta
go see you guys Monday